right sam has been getting himself in
hot water with
pretty much everyone over the last few
months so i've been thinking about why
and i reckon i've worked out a big part
of it as far as i can tell
most people who are upset with him are
accusing sam of confusion or hypocrisy
regarding his seemingly contradictory
views
for instance how can sam be against
critical race theory
and also for biden in the last election
how can he be against queuing on and
also against antifa how can he be
critical of the blm riots and yet also
called trump responsible for the capital
hill rights how can he be in solidarity
with his audience
and also refer to q anon as being a
youtube comment thread come to life
how can sam denounce the capital hill
writers and also say that the behavior
of the police
would not have been different if blm had
stormed the capital i
i get it i don't agree with everything
sam said over the last few months
and he very well may hate trump so much
that it's skewing his worldview but that
doesn't explain why people are getting
so mad at him i think this does
humans like people who they can predict
easily this is why archetypes are used
in movies it speeds up our understanding
of the character
the hero is always muscled the nerd
always has glasses the maiden has big
eyes the villain wears black
we take one element of that person and
extrapolate that out to infer the rest
of who they are this
suits our brains just fine because it
requires almost
no work our brains are energy saving
machines
so the more assumptions they can make
about the world the less
thinking needs to be done to work out
what's actually happening the problem is
encountered when someone does something
which is
outside of the predictive model our
brain had them filed away under our
brains aren't evolved to deal with
people who hold
differing complex views of reality
someone is a feminist but doesn't
support abortion someone votes labor or
democrat
but also believes in stringent
immigration checks someone
supports biden and also accuses his
policies of causing a tsunami of
wokeness
flooding across america before the what
about isms appear in your brain
i'm not saying that any of these stances
are even slightly incompatible
there will be lots of people who
actually have those blends of beliefs
but
very few of them ever appear in
discussions online
and anyone who does is immediately
destroyed
why is that firstly having a non-typical
perspective on an element of
your group's ideology is often seen by
the other side
as weakness or a lack of conviction it's
seen as a signal that you're actually an
uneducated hypocrite
who doesn't know what they're supposed
to believe it's much safer
to go out all guns blazing with the most
extreme views possible
leaving no chinks in the armor secondly
having a non-typical perspective is seen
by
your side as a lack of commitment and
identification with the shared values of
your own group
if you disagree with us on this topic
then what else can't we trust you about
it's much safer
for people to avoid bringing attention
to themselves by holding a nuance view
so they just adopt the group ideology
wholesale having a balanced viewpoint
essentially just makes you an unreliable
ally and this
is weaponized by a third element that
the internet is just a hyper-vigilant
hypocrisy dunk fest
especially on twitter all that most
people are there for is to find a
self-contradiction
closet racism or microaggression in
others online and then just highlight it
with the sharpest
most emotional language possible no one
is actually concerned with discovering
truth all they want is to look slick and
cool and to climb the state the ladder
by getting one over on someone else
my least favorite sentence on the
internet is because of your view
on issue x i can't take your opinion on
completely unrelated issue y
seriously and this is why everybody is
getting mad at sam at least when you're
out on the extremes you get agreement
from one side but when you're in the
middle
you guarantee disagreement from both on
a video i published about the capital
hill riots some people from both the
left and the right
consider the analysis unfair but for the
complete opposite reasons i even got a
reply this week
which literally suggested that a
balanced viewpoint is the opposite of
having a real opinion honestly
just bring on the robot overlords
because we here
i don't agree with everything sam says
but i trust him far more
because he has had to do lots of work to
arrive at his non-typical viewpoint we
all should be
incredibly skeptical of anyone who takes
that ideology wholesale if i know
one of your beliefs and from it i can
accurately predict
everything else that you believe then
you're not a serious person sam
consistently says
my mind is not made up on the specifics
and he suffers far more criticism for
being nuanced than he would for being an
absolutist so it's safe to presume
that he truly believes what he's saying
sam's benefit is that this independent
thought gives him a far deeper insight
into situations
because he can see both sides in my
opinion his can we pull back from the
brink podcast episode
around the blm protests last year was
the best
sense making anyone on earth did around
it being for
or against a thing does not mean that
you are universally
on side with the other people who are
also for or against it in 2021
the heaviest price is not paid by the
people out on the extremes
it's the moderates in the middle who get
hated by everyone the internet
only seems to have one emotional volume
now and it's 11. sadly that causes
people to retreat to these
boring tired repetitive tropes of
absolutist thinking
if you want to be a serious thinker you
need strong opinions
loosely held not loose opinions strongly
held you acquire wisdom
by disregarding group thing let me know
what you think in the comments below
and for more uncomfortable truths press
subscribe peace